i used to worry a lot about what people
thought of me and there's this quote
about i think it's like george bernard
shaw about how you'd worry
you know a lot less about what people
think of you you know once you realize
how seldom they do like most people
actually don't really care that's right
um but we're all trapped in this we're
all trapped in like um
you know thinking about our actions our
behavior our decisions as you know
what's somebody going to to think and i
actually think it's very empowering to
be able to say you know i
what is important to me what is
important to me and to ask questions of
yourself because often it's not just
other people that are holding you back
like you're the one that's holding back
very often um and so i just kind of
learned to ask these why questions why
do i i just for a long time i had this
like screen saver on my laptop and
whenever i open the laptop it it says
like why are you doing this basically so
i kind of have to like look at that
every time like why am i doing this you
know like we get in these patterns of um
this is my routine i'm just doing this
by rote and i started questioning that
more and more and that helped me to make
better decisions and ended up developing
this into you know a bit more of a
philosophy and a community that people
have kind of latched on to
but ultimately it's about thinking for
yourself you know choosing for yourself
and also trying to make the world a
better place i don't think they're
they're exclusive
yeah i i like the the way you put it and
by the way would you say that's what
inspired the world domination or was the
world domination inspired art of
non-conformity
i started the art of non-conformity
first and then i wrote a manifesto
called a brief guide to world domination
that was like just outlining some of my
ideas i liked a very provocative title
you know like people are passionate
around and stuff and then from there
i was like
let's bring everybody together let's do
like i was doing meetups in different
cities when i was traveling it's really
interesting because the people who came
out they all had their own story they're
all like working on stuff and they often
felt uh maybe misunderstood you know by
some people around them
a lot of them did want to start a
business and they were in kind of
traditional jobs they were trying to
figure out how to navigate that so i was
like let's bring everybody together and
i called it the world domination summit
you know so it kind of grew from there
so we've been doing that for for nine
years now
i love that title world domination
summit now the the concern would be is
your last name a german last name
uh it is not okay that means
know you start that you choose something
like nine years ago and you kind of live
with it for a long time like maybe i
wouldn't call it that necessarily now
you know for a variety of reasons but uh
you know that's okay it is what it is i
love it that's i mean i i just have to
tell you i love that i love the freaking
title and uh i don't know the number but
i i saw somewhere around 10 000 people
have come over the years
and uh you put some great events
together which is great but let's go
back let's go now back to the uh uh you
know if you were
14 years old right it's a different
world to day 14 than when you and i were
14
you know some i don't know what the
number is 14 was what 29 years ago for
us right when we were 14 that sounds
like a long time so when you and i were
14
i made money i don't i would buy 90s 99
hats and i would sell them for seven
bucks i'd buy cards
and i would flip them i'd buy you know
hats shoes you know a bunch of weird
things that i would sell right but i
wonder what we would do if we were 14
today in high school so i'll turn it to
you how how would you make money today
as a young teenager young entrepreneur
at 14 years old
so i think this is really interesting
because
you know no doubt so much has changed as
you said in all those years i can't
believe it's been you know 29 years as
you said so much has changed you know
like the iphone wasn't out there now we
have all these different platforms you
know we're much more connected than we
were etc etc new business models however
you know the way that you got started in
business the way that i got started
it's actually still quite relevant like
reselling is still very accessible most
of it hasn't changed that much you know
like most of it in terms of like you're
trying to find the 99 cent hat you know
maybe it costs like five bucks now
you're trying to sell that for 30 bucks
or whatever and
i mean people can do that there's all
kinds and like there's so many platforms
now with facebook marketplace and offer
up and gumtree and all kinds of others
um without a lot of capital at all i
mean 50 bucks even even if you don't
have any money you can start with the
stuff that you already have like sell
your own stuff and then use that 50
bucks to buy other stuff
you know i mean it's it's a process and
that may not be in you know what you end
up doing for your whole life you know
like you're going to go on to other
stuff
but by doing that you're going to learn
about marketing you're going to learn
about how to accept payments you're
going to learn about customer service
you're going to learn about copywriting
all this kind of all these kind of
skills that will that will help so i
think that's always a great first start
i mean the second thing would be
okay so once you have a little bit of
experience
you know now you know it doesn't really
matter if you're 14
anyone can have you know a website
that's actually like doing some kind of
e-commerce thing anybody can offer a
service you know online nobody cares if
you're 14. like it's not really relevant
it's it's like what is the product what
is the service you know so there i feel
like
you know we could look at all sorts of
different things but it depends on what
your goal is if you're trying to just
make some money and get into it really
quickly make more money than you would
you know working
you know at a restaurant or something
then you can do that today so if you
like this sort of short clip from an
interview i did click over here to watch
the entire interview and
please don't forget to subscribe to the
channel take care everybody bye
[Music]